alex und kollegen mein name ist müssen
und ich hätte zwei sein kollege erste
frage klingt zwar lächerlich aber
trotzdem das
zweite frage wer wann etwas
wieder mit beiden banken
hieß
dann hätte ich auch mal sucht genannt
auf ihr hab und gut movies ttv sein
wasser dem movies tv ist ein kanal ok ok
yahoo news tv abonniert alle seinen
kanal moderat den geilsten haarschnitt
den ich seit langem gesehen habe er
behalten auf jeden fall dabei massoud
sie ja deine fragen
auch wieder farid fragen musste war klar
das wolle natürlich die ganzen
wissen wann kommen wieder was mit dem
banker aus derendorf
wie gesagt wir setzen uns in extremo und
besprechen die lage
und da werde ich bereit fragen genau wie
du fragst wie ist die lage und dann
werden wir weiter sehen ja was wird
begeht zwei anbelangt wird natürlich
legendär ich weiß noch damals also wird
bg gemacht haben alle haben erstmal
gerettet und haben gesagt was machst du
mit dem marokkaner war jetzt werden
haben gesagt was machst du mit dem
deutschen auf einmal so ich gehe auf die
straße mittlerweile jeder sagt man kommt
der zweite teil dann kommt der zweite
teil baust du musst nach deren dorf
fahren macht die jungen brutal
gutaussehend wg wieder aufmacht endlich
den zweiten teil
und sowas geht mir dann doch ans herz
und deswegen ich denke das wird bald zu
sein inschallah money money boy oder du
wie du gesagt hast meine war das glaube
ich habe ich für money boy
money boy ein ein lustiger zeitgenosse
mit dem wir viel spaß gehabt haben und
der uns das eine oder andere lächeln auf
die lippen gezaubert hat wo ist er jetzt
frage ich mich wo ist er hin unser mann
weißt du es glauben was halten sie von
ihm was ich von ihm halte was hältst du
davon hast du ja interview du hast ja
besser kennengelernt als ich würde sagen
unglaubliche energie aber an seiner rap
techniken wie siehst du das sagst sogar
ein außenstehender der mit rap bis vor
kurzem nichts am hut hatte der einfach
nur jetzt hier klick so macht um ein
paar klicks abzustauben und sein konto
auf sich doch wie unser christoph nein
also spaß beiseite money boy natürlich
kein ist jetzt nicht die rap technische
offenbarung des jahrhunderts aber dumm
ist ja auch nicht ich habe mir das
interview angeguckt mit euch beiden und
was er da von sich gegeben hat war jetzt
gar nicht so dass ihr uns hätte ich aber
auch einmal ein konzert von mir und hat
mir so ein schönes porträt gemalt von
mehreren kollegen darauf geschrieben so
schön zeichentrick mäßig gemalt hat er
mich
und ich kann nichts schlechtes gingen
dann sagen rappen kann jetzt nicht so
optimal aber das konnte ich jetzt vor
zehn jahren auch noch nicht und in
diesem sinne alles gute moneyball weiter
so lass dich nicht unterkriegen